by the way M Farmers have you ever asked
yourself this question how many number
of bags do you produce in your small
piece of land do you produce such number
of BS because you assume you know how to
farm these or it's because of ignorance
to learn new knowledge on how you can
grow much
better well I don't want you to answer
me that but today we are focusing on the
basic on how you can manage to grow Maze
and get high from planting to harvesting
including the best soil for me farming
and we're going to jump lat away on the
best soil for ma
fing maze drives in Fertile l or Sunday
L soils supplementing these soils with
cow or shap manure can enhance growth
and when it rains this mixure retains
moisture further promoting growth
conversely clay soil can has poor
drainage and can lead to flooding which
starts growth and results in no yeat
after getting light on the best s for ma
family now let's focus on which are
these best varieties of maze that you
can plant in Kenya and get good needs
now the suitability of maze varieties
varies by regions in the Norther region
where there is only one maze season five
month maze varieties are the best these
varieties have high producing over 50 PS
of 90 kg per acre some of the
recommended varieties include Pioneer
v253 Pioneer v g90 h64 h628 h 629 it is
crucial to plant these varieties during
the long range season for the best
results in Legion with two M Seasons
Farmers should op for three month
maturity maze varieties these fast
maturing varieties such as haraka 101
haraka 31 Dum 43 SC 301 DK c31 DK h33
and sa V
4141 typically yield an average of 25 to
35 90 kg bags per acre and matures
within 75 to 90 days after getting it
right on the best mze varieties then how
well do you plant this seeds before
planting ensure the land is clear of
food farmers can either weed manually or
you can use n selective herbicides such
as CA or Roundup a recommended plant is
spacing of 60 cm by 30 cm compared to
the traditional 90 CM by 25 cm increases
CR population per requiring a c rate of
11 to 12 kg per and of course the yield
if using a maze planter calibrate it
first for precise spacing after planting
this crop need to be fed with the best
fertilizers and then that's how we give
you the best maze
fertilizers us P are influenced not only
by the maze variety but also by proper
fertilization High crop populations
require adequate Fe to bless with dap
18460 on the 10th day after sewing to
promote faster growth at this stage the
maze plants have developed strong roots
that can absorb nitrogen and phosphorus
effectively using fertilizers during
planting is not effective as seeds do
not utilize them leading to reaching dap
is preferred of NPK 23230 due to its
high phosphorus content which supports
rapid root growth NPK 23230 should be
top on after sewing or C fertilizer
should be applied 55 days after sewing
to enhance seed formation and with game
after planting you need to control the
past the full arm is a significant past
in M fing responsible for more than 50%
of crop cost to control F apply Amon
that PC or escort ideally 21 to 40 days
later that is after sewing this should
be combined with a sticker such as
Integra or aqua and a booster or for
feed this application is most effective
when done in the late evening when the
full army war is most
effective when you've done this you need
Now to control weed keep the farm free
of weight at all times this is essential
farmers can choose between manual
weeding or using selective hites such as
tinga governor maguma theine to for
this all this they simplify the work of
controlling whe also implementing zero
to L can help conserve moisture thereby
promoting faster growth now with all
this you have a complete gu that you can
follow step by step and manage to yield
more from your small P of land let me
know on the comment section if you have
any question or query about m and also
ma management and P control
[Music]